well in many cases there is no justice
as just minimizing the injustice we're
mitigating the injustice for example if
a woman has been raped or battered you
can't undo the rape and can't undo the
battery the bruises the you know broken
arm the other injuries that may have
been inflicted upon her but we can do is
try to minimize the injustice by winning
her compensation and sometimes criminal
prosecution as well for the wrong that
has been done to her civilly and
sometimes criminally and so it's all
about accountability and imposing
appropriate consequences for the person
and on the person who has inflicted the
wrong and the harm and the damage for me
it's all about winning whatever it is my
client is seeking that is possible in
legal system we do not live in an ideal
world we live in a world that is
somewhat flawed and we work in a flawed
justice system having said that we want
to win as much justice or minimize the
injustice to the fullest extent possible
so in some cases that means criminal
prosecution and civil settlement
sometimes it's just civil settlement but
i would like to win whatever end
whenever it is possible to do so as much
justice as the system can afford
I do think it has an educational impact
having to reach into one's wallet and
pay out a large amount because of the
wrong that one has done definitely makes
one think about whether one wants to do
this again to someone else because there
is a cost to inflict Imran real question
is who should bear the cost of the wrong
I say it should not be the victim should
be the wrongdoer and that's the message
i'm trying to send so for example in
many cases involving sexual harassment
that's mainly what we do is plaintiff
sexual harassment for individuals who've
been sexually harassed then you know we
want the full measure of damages that is
possible under the law from the sexual
harasser and/or those who might have
condoned or encouraged that sexual
harassment because sexual harassment is
a barrier to the enjoyment of equal
employment opportunity so for example a
woman who sexually harassed in the
workplace is going to have to battle
that fight that if she says yes to the
sexual harassment because she's afraid
to lose her job if she doesn't then
she's in a no-win situation if she says
no then she's in a no-win situation it's
not fair it's not right and it's against
the law so we want to get her
compensation so she can go on with her
life and be free of that barrier sexual
harassment we've done child sexual abuse
cases we've been able to get the abusers
prosecuted the child molester is
prosecuted and also sometimes filed
civil lawsuits against them resulting in
very significant damages that have to be
paid to the victim of child sexual abuse
same with rapists and others who have
inflicted wrongs against women and
children
you